bonsoir seven lui thierry ardisson alors
revue de presse de la semaine par
stéphane guillon mesdames messieurs
politique sarkozy a une sexualité
étrange regardez ces photos il ferme la
bouche pour embrasser sa femme mais ils
l'ouvrent pour serrer la main d'un homme
déviance toujours pour faire ressortir
sa féminité michèle alliot-marie exige
que nos militaires se déguise en drag
queen
bertrand delanoë sans état d'âme
derrière ségolène royal titre libération
bah oui mais bon où est l'info derrière
une femme bertrange jamais eu d'état
d'âme
après le scandale des viandes avariées
perquisition chez les éleveurs de porcs
le qg du front national a été contrôlé
ségolène royal refuse de se rendre à
deauville parce que c'est une ville de
riches fidèle à ses convictions elle
passe ses vacances dans un quartier très
difficile sur la côte d'azur à mougins
une zone de non droit où après 19 heures
on peut se faire attaquer par des
cigales à 8000 euros le mètre carré ségo
et condamné à payer les sf pour vivre
dans ce bouge c'est terrible avec la
même bravoure ségolène a assisté à
l'avant première du film de christophe
malavoy alors là bravo elle est ressorti
complètement bouleversé sud en chantier
métamorphose houde
international une mission très difficile
confie à madame de fontenay à organiser
l'élection de miss talibans
international toujours renault renonce à
soutenir ingrid betancourt pour une
vraie cause humanitaire la
réhabilitation de vieux animateurs
méchant et gris il ya du taf
société dans vsd un reportage sur les
mamans sexagénaire à quand une mère
octogénaire une formule très économique
en cas d'incontinence de la maman elle
peut se servir des couches de bébé
on va passer à table c'est bien
record de naissances en france
830 mille nourrisson en 2006 autant de
bébés frais c'est une aubaine pour le
coup en 2007 inutile donc congelés on a
ce qu'il faut
vie pratique les soupes liebig affiche
des noms de plus en plus affriolants
partage entre amis réconfort divers
enfin si vraiment vous aimez la soupe la
mélasse vous avez aussi ensemble tout
devient possible
merci christophe
fait divers une prof de tango décapité
c'est emmerdant c'est quand tu danse le
tango le moment le plus gracieux c'est
quand tu renverses la tête de ta
partenaire si elle en a plus et c'est
chiant
mais messieurs
gym elle m'a dit déclare ben gala ce que
je ressens sur scène et parfois plus
fort qu'un orgasme ça tombe bien on
préfère l'applaudir que coucher avec
[Applaudissements]
me paul inquiétudes du parisien stéphane
bern devra peut-il se raser la tête pour
jouer dans le prochain jean-pierre mocky
alors je rassure le parisien je connais
bien stéphane inutile de le raser faut
juste bien décoller sa moumoute et il
peut travailler
après la publication d'un match de
photos d'un djihad défiguré régine
renonce à entreprendre un nouveau
lifting
dans vsd un spécial monstre marin le
dragon noir la lotte épineuse est
également présente à la soirée paris
première la josée dayan
pure
people toujours stupeur lors d'un gala
caritatif sur le thème du cirque zidane
aurait mis un coup de boule à sa monture
littérature un ouvrage de poésie
érotique signée serge la maj le site les
vagins sont des carrefours où se
côtoient bits et bouche c'est beau on
dirait du pascal sevran sauf que pascal
les vagins il les évite et les beats si
elles sont noires il les coupes
on termine par un scoop après les photos
de jean luc delarue nu à saint barth une
autre photo volée et là peut être un
début d'explication à ces complexes
pascal sevran à la plage
[Rires]
c'est 20 millions les corrections de ne
rien rater le in a l'habitude abonnez
vous je m'étais un peu de bleu